One.
Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook.
If you don't have one, you can go to
www.40daysofholiness.com and order yours,
okay? Let's get started, and let's look into the holiness of God today.
Here's today's theme: All things are holy only
as they relate to God.
I'm not an iPhone guy, but I have noticed while shopping for my wife's
iPhone charger, yes, we are a house divided, very sad, pray for her.
I've noticed that there are some fake products out there.
That they work for Apple, but they're not made by Apple, and
eventually they break down or they don't work well.
If you're a mechanic, there are aftermarket parts that might not fit, and
then there are OEM parts, original equipment
manufacturer parts. Those fit, right?
It's the same way in holiness. The only real thing comes from
connection to God. He's the OEM. He's the original
equipment manufacturer, and nothing else actually fits.
There's no intrinsic holiness in any person or thing.
Most human religions teach that there is intrinsic holiness in
some person or place or thing, that this person is holy because of
some quality they possess. This is a holy object, holy place,
holy rock, holy ceremony, those kinds of things.
So we get titles like His Holiness the Dalai Lama or Holy
Father about the Pope. But when the Bible uses the word,
it's not talking about that. The Bible teaches there's no such thing
as intrinsic holiness, holiness that exists in a
place or a person just by themselves.
But when God comes into the picture, when he touches or uses
something, he communicates his holiness to or
through that person or thing. Let me give you an example.
Exodus 3, when you read, "The ground where you were standing," God said to
Moses, "is holy ground." What made that ground holy? Was it a special place?
No, just a bush and some wilderness ground.
But now it's holy. Why? Because God's there.
In the scripture, bread is holy, and God says it's his.
Oil, pots, sacrifices, a day he
created or the Mosaic Sabbath,
gold. In fact, in Matthew 23:17, Jesus asked the crowd,
he said, "Which is greater, the gold or the temple that makes the gold sacred,
makes it holy?"
Well, what's that mean? Well, Jesus is saying that the gold in the temple is holy.
Why is the temple holy? It's special? No, no.
The reason the temple's holy is that God chose to place his
presence there. It's he's there, so it's holy.
He uses it, so it's holy. God's presence or touch or use
makes things holy that were not holy before.
This is also true of people. When God connects with us, we
become holy. His presence in us makes us holy,
even though we weren't before.
So God says in 1 Corinthians 7 that as a
believing wife, you make your husband and your kids holy, even if they're not
believers. They're in contact with you, and God's in contact
with you, so they are in contact with holiness.
Have you ever touched something and you got a shock? That's static electricity.
Static electricity is electricity that builds up in a person or item.
But there's another kind of electricity that doesn't just build up and sit
there. It flows through a connection, a
plug, or a wire. When the switch is off, the connection's
broken, and the light goes off. God's holiness is not
like static electricity. It's like the other kind.
Like electricity flows, holiness is dynamic.
If God leaves or stops using something or is
disconnected from something, it's not holy. Just like that, the light goes off.
My little boys, I've got six sons, and they have a little board called Snap
Circuits, and it snaps together. You make circuits and put in
resistors and a siren that goes
and a light, and it's all connected back to a battery pack, a
source, and they can make different things.
And the first element of holiness is like
that circuit. It all has to go back to the source.
The only thing that creates holiness is being connected
to God. And if you're connected to God, you are holy.
No matter if you used to be or not. And if you're not connected to
God, you're not connected to holiness.
The light goes off because He is the source of all of it.
So rather than I'm going to grit my teeth and make myself holy because I
do holy actions,
the source of holiness is a connection to, a filling
with, a use by God, who is the fountainhead,
the source, and the definition of all holiness.
So what you're longing for when you're longing to be holy
is not so much a let's try to do some more holy things.
It is I need to be connected to the only thing that is the
source of all holiness in this universe, and that's God.
So together, we're going to strive to be that kind of person.
That's where we're headed during this time.
Let's talk about it some more tomorrow.
Right now, I want you to go ahead and grab your workbook and
spend time with the sample prayers and the meditation questions,
and I'll see you back here tomorrow.